tema fútbol juan porque hacemos el
seguimiento hablando de mujeres al
histórico acuerdo de equidad salarial
que se dio ayer en eeuu raúl como les
hemos contado de nuestras emisiones se
trata de un acuerdo pionero que promete
una paridad total entre hombres y
mujeres de la selección absoluta de eeuu
esto incluye un reparto equitativo de
las bonificaciones y premios incluyendo
el mundial y también las ganancias de
derechos comerciales y derechos de
transmisión según estimaciones de
sindicatos de las futbolistas hasta 2018
una mujer bajo contrato podría tener
unas ganancias máximas de unos 245 mil
dólares ahora bajo este nuevo acuerdo
que expira en 2028 una mujer con este
contrato anualmente si es convocada a
todas las que valga la redundancia
convocatorias de la selección femenina
de eeuu podría ganar hasta 450 mil
dólares y esta cifra se podría duplicar
según el rendimiento que tengan en los
mundiales es decir según avancen en esta
copa del mundo porque eso ofrece más
ganancias más bonificaciones para poner
en contexto la brecha salarial veamos
estas otras cifras en 2019 el equipo
femenino de eeuu ganó la copa mundo en
francia y recibió una bonificación
de huesos de 110 mil dólares
la bonificación fijada para el equipo
masculino era de 407 mil dólares pero
recordemos que el equipo masculino de
eeuu no se clasificó a esa copa mundo
veamos otra cifra la suma de los premios
de la fifa que hubo para el mundial
masculino de rusia 2018 fue de 400
millones de dólares la suma de los
premios para el mundial femenino de
francia de 2019 fue de 30 millones de
dólares vale recordar que la fifa está
trabajando en eso para el próximo
mundial 2023 dicen que quieren que esa
cifra de 30 millones pase a ser de 60
millones de dólares